At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Marsha Murray
and Pat C. Jackson to give us the presentation on
Office of Business Opportunity budget. Presentation.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon. Is my mic on?
Yes, ma'am. Okay. Good afternoon, mayor Pro TEM,
Vice Chair and Council members, I'm pleased to present OBO's
proposed fiscal year 23 budget today. I'm joined
today by OBO's Chief Financial Officer Patsy Jackson.
I'd also like to recognize some of the OBO team members that are here today.
Lala Morris Obio's assistant director,
as well as Pearl Cahalas, our council liaison and
Pio. In his absence, I'd also like to acknowledge Tim
Warren, who's our Certification and Designation Division Manager,
and two supervisors who are overseeing our Contract Compliance
Division at this point, Shanita Petway, as well as Jamante Huey.
I thank you all for your fabulous work, your tremendous work in
moving the core services of the Office of Business Opportunity forward.
Next slide, please. At the Office of
Business Opportunity, we execute our mission of cultivating a competitive
and diverse economic environment and the City of Houston by promoting the success
of small businesses and developing Houston's workforce, with a
special emphasis on historically underutilized businesses and disenfranchised
individuals through the provision of several core services.
Next slide, please. This slide
represents our organizational chart. Fund 1000 covers OBO's
core services, including executive Oversight,
Certification, contract compliance, and External affairs and
workforce development. Accounting for our $5.4 million budget
and approximately 43 FTEs.
The Executive Leadership team includes myself,
the Assistant Director, our Chief Financial Officer, the Citywide
Title VI Compliance Coordinator and our one person analytics
and reporting team. Our Certification and Designation
Division administers six local certifications and two
federal certifications on behalf of the US. Department of Transportation.
Those certifications are listed here. In addition, we facilitate
historically underutilized business certification on behalf of
the State of Texas, and our newest certification added to
our directory is the Lgbtbe certification. The Division
also processes applications for the city's local preference program. The Higher
Houston First program, the Contract Compliance Division,
monitors all city contracts with the exception of housing and airport contracts,
to ensure compliance with the minority Women's Small Business Enterprise program
requirements and to enforce local and federal labor
standards, including prevailing wage compliance and prompt payment requirements on
city contracts. Our External Affairs team raises
awareness of OBO services and the city's contracting opportunities
and also provides local businesses with access to business development
resources. This team also administers business development and
capacity building programs. And finally, our Workforce Development team
facilitates initiatives such as the Turnaround Houston job in a Readiness Fair.
Next slide, please. So this slide
represents our Special Fund, Fund 24 24, which covers
the Contractor Responsibility Fund, which supports the
administrative and programmatic operations of the city's. Payer Play Program
The Payer Play Program aims to level the playing field for contracts
between bidders that choose to offer health benefits to
their workforce and those who do not. The program also
offsets the cost of providing health care to uninsured people in
the Houston Harris County area. The Contractor Responsibility
Fund supports three city programs and those programs are listed on
this slide. Next slide, please.
So, in the interest of time, I will ask you to review at
your election slides five and six, which provides more details about
our core services. I'll skip over to slide seven.
So, while we do have some flexibility in terms
of delivering OBS core services, there are statutory requirements
for components of our services at the local, state and federal
levels. Federal funding is tied to our Title Six
certification and contract compliance work. As it
relates to certification, federal regulations require that all recipients of
Department of Transportation funding in excess of $250,000
in a federal fiscal year are required to have a Disadvantaged Business Enterprise
program to ensure nondiscrimination in the award and administration
of Department of Transportation assisted contracts. Failure to properly
administer the aforementioned programs can result in a loss of
Federal funding. Next slide, please.
So, this slide we are describing the financial and societal impact
of our service deliveries. The services that OBO administers
have broad societal impact for not only small business owners,
but also their employees. Obio's contract compliance team advocates
for and enforces the rights of certified firms on contracts
with goals, and ensures that employees of City of Houston construction
contractors are paid appropriate wages, ultimately supporting the
local economy and improving the lives of Houstonians.
Revenues collected from the Paraplay program offset the cost of
providing health care to uninsured Houstonians.
The City's Title Six program ensures equal access to
city facilities and program in by all Houstonians.
And our certification program serves to expand opportunities for firms
as they can be utilized on City of Houston projects and on projects with other
area agencies and private companies. Some of those companies or
entities are listed at the bottom of this slide. Next slide,
please. And this
slide discusses the anticipated growth in number of customers
that we expect in fiscal year 23. We expect an increased
demand for MWSBE certification due to new
MWBE programs in the region, such as the Harris County
and Poor Houston race and gender conscious programs. We also expect
demands from businesses seeking to participate in the Houston based
NCWA Final Four Supplier Diversity Initiative next
year. And we also anticipate that there will be additional
opportunities for firms brought
on by infrastructure projects.
HPW has also predicted that there will
be an increase in the number of contracts that
are let. As a result, we anticipate an increase in our overall
contract compliance monitoring workload. And finally,
the Northeast Water Purification Plant Project has approximately
931 project 930
subcontractors participating and growing.
This project will increase our MWSBE contract
compliance monitoring and prevailing wage and labor standards monitoring.
Next slide, please. So at this time, I will ask Ms.
Jackson to discuss the projected revenues and expenditures in our
proposed FY 23 budget on
our revenue by funds. The General Fund revenue indicated on the first
row of this slide increased by 74% and
FY 23 over FY 22. The special revenue on
the second row increased by 7.94%, and FY 23
over FY 22. Let's go to the next slide and give a little
bit more information about that. These are our revenue highlights.
The FY 23 General Fund proposed budget increased by
74% is due to the three additional FTEs transferring from
the Houston Public Works Department. This revenue consists of HPW's
contributions to support our contract compliance staff, which currently
funds nine positions. The General Fund revenue
supports the City's Payer Play program, the FY 23 budget
increased by 7.94% and it is attributed
to anticipated increases to the revenue that supports Fund 24 24.
Of note, though, Houston Public Works estimate a 6% increase
in revenue due to an increase of vendors participating in the
pay portion of the pay or play program working on the new
project. Houston Airport System anticipate
projects moving from design to construction phase, and more contracts
awarded using the pay option will result in increased
revenue, and the Housing and Community Development Department anticipates
more contracts in FY 23 which will increase revenue by 15%
to 20%. Next slide, please.
Expenditure by Fund Obio's FY 22 General Fund estimate
budget for Fund 1000 is 4.1 million. The 5.4
million proposed budget for FY 23 reflected on this slide shows a
32.58% increase due to two additional
position in OBO Solutions Center, which will manage new business
programs and increase the visibility of the Department services.
Three employees transfer from HPW to the Contract Compliance Division to
assist in managing the HPW contracts, two additional
positions for the certification division and a onetime funding for vendor
augmented contract monitoring to ensure compliance with
statutory requirements. The special revenue
expenditure line item reflects expenditures for administrative and pragmatic
operations of the City's payer play program. This fund shows a 31.30%
decrease because the one time funding in FY 22 for ethan Houston
Fire Department personnel is not included in FY 23 budget.
In FY 23, this fund supports funding for health
benefits, pension contribution and municipal employees contractual
pay increases funded to maintain an electronic management system
to effectively track all pay or play activities. The FY 23
budget continues to support the contractor responsibility funds
initiatives such as the Client Access Program,
crisis called Diversion Program, and the Emergency Telehealth
and Navigation Ethan program. Next slide, please.
Why FY 23 personnel versus nonpersonal for Fund 1000
OBO's proposed budget of 5.4 million,
82% of that covers personnel expenses,
salaries and French benefits. Of the remaining 18%
of our budget, 4% covers restricted charge accounts
that are charged backs by the City of Houston, 1% covers the cost
of the B City Certification and Contract Compliance
Management system, and 13% covers other services including
the contract monitoring program, the printing and reproduction,
professional development and training for our employees. Next slide
please. Slide 14, which is the FY 23
personnel versus nonpersonal for fund 24. 24 covers the
Contractor Responsibility Fund, which supports the operations of the City
of Houston payroll play program. 15% of that budget will
fund personnel expenses such as salaries, fringe benefits for
the administrative responsible for the financial and program oversight.
The other 85% of the budget will fund the three listed
program and technology costs. Next slide, please.
Slide 15 is our FY 23 budget expenditure net
Change. This slide is a visual representation of the
net change and general fund budget that we discussed
earlier. Go to the next slide, please.
Slide 16 and 17. They both details what
we discussed early in our presentation. And that
concludes our financial portion of OBO's budget, and I will
refer that back to our director. Thank you. And thank you. And that
concludes our presentation. Before I take questions, I'd like to briefly highlight
the appendix that follows, which you can review at your election.
The appendix provides additional information, including Oba's
organizational chart, a breakdown of staff demographics,
Obia's FY two accomplishments which we're very proud of,
and some of our unmet needs. Thank you,
Council Member Ed Pollan. Thank you,
Chair, and thank you, Director, for your presentation and to your
entire staff for all the great work that you all do. I know you
make the most with a little, and it's appreciated and valued.
A couple of questions. We had a Disparity
study done, correct? We did. How much was that
Disparity study? Why are we not using that Disparity study?
And in the Disparity study, is it breaking down
opportunities based on specific race?
Okay, so we did commission a Disparity study that
will not be published. I'm sorry. Is it are
we good? Okay, so the city did commission a Disparity study,
and because there are concerns about
the methodology that was used to perform the Disparity study, the city
will not be publishing that study. So I cannot speak
about any of the substantive how long was that Disparity study covering?
What years did it cover? So it's covered twelve through
16 fiscal years,
1230 fiscal years.
Twelve through 16. And how much money did we spend on that? It cost a
little bit under a million dollars. And we're not publishing it at all?
No. And so now, to my
understanding, we are looking to do another Disparity study. So there's
currently an RFP that is on
the street soliciting proposals for a new
Disparity study covering fiscal years
through fiscal year 17, through fiscal year 21,
a five year period, and who makes a determination on whether the
methodology was something that we believe
is useful or not. So the determination
is really based on the
experience with administering programs like this,
particularly the kind of program that
we have. Without going into substantive
details about what's contained within that draft study.
It really did not. I believe in the memo that I wrote to the mayor
that was shared with council members. I believe
I included in that memo that it really did not reflect the way
in which the City of Houston administers its program.
You put me back in the queue. Thank you.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM martha Castex Tatum. Thank you, Director Murray.
Thank you for your presentation. I'm curious to know,
last budget cycle, we put forth a budget amendment
for some additional dollars to get caught up on our contract compliance.
Where are we in that process, and have we made any progress with
getting caught up on our contract compliance? So I am
happy to report that the mayor has, as part of the fiscal year
22s budget, he's actually provided additional funding for
us to actually augment and our our existing contract
compliance monitoring services through the engagement of vendors. So additional
information will be provided shortly about that engagement,
because as is the case with other departments,
we're certainly not immune to the
great resignation. And so we have lost a
substantial number of our compliance officers,
which is why there has been this urgency to
actually augment our existing services.
Unfortunately, we've only been able to, and we're
just having issues attracting compliance officers. So we
had seven compliance offers. We're now up
to two compliance officers. So really, the rest of the remaining
of the staff is really all hands on deck in terms of trying to
address the workload that currently exists. What's the pay
for a compliance officer? So, for a
compliance officer, it's approximately 48,000. For a senior compliance officer,
it's approximately 56,000,
and the qualifications for it. And so the
compliance officer requires a bachelor's degree and
one year experience, or years of experience can
be substituted year for year for the bachelor's degree. For a senior compliance
officer, the difference is two years experience. Okay.
Thank you, Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you,
Chair. Sometimes when we have contracts
that come out, we're looking for MWBEs to participate,
but we get word that there aren't any in
the directory or there's a void for minority vendors
in that particular industry space. Do we keep a log of
where we may have voids and try to find ways to identify
minority companies within the city that
if we were to reach out to them, could participate
in certain contracts? So we're not necessarily keeping
a log, but we are aware of some of the areas where
there are gaps. So when our
external affairs team actually goes on to the community, they may actually
emphasize the fact that there are opportunities in a particular area
and encourage for firms
to get certified. And we are generally just looking to
increase the number of firms and the variety,
the diversity in terms of industry, the diversity of firms
that are actually certified. And when it comes
to the openings that you have,
so those are current openings that people can go online right now
and apply for those positions. Yeah. Any opening that
we have that has not been closed because we've
exhausted the period for which the posting is out absolutely are
available on the City's website. We do, actually, because we recognize
the challenges in
reaching out to people. So we have social media. My external affairs
team has created social media campaigns. We have
leveraged our advisory board members to actually reach
out to their network of folks to
talk about our various positions. We are perpetually talking ad
nauseam about these positions. And we've also
been just internally talking about reevaluating some of the postings
that we put out there. We certainly want to be clear about
what the responsibilities of the position, but we also want to talk
about the benefits, lead with the benefits of working
for the city, lead with the benefits of the impact. That the kind of work
that you can do as a compliance officer can have on the lives of people.
But I think you all do a tremendous job of putting out information.
I'm always getting updates. I think we as a council should
collaborate more on making sure our constituents have that information.
So whatever information you do have on current openings,
please send to my office. Sure. Thank you.
So just a quick follow up on Council Member Pollard's initial
line of questions on the Disparity study. So we issued
an RFP. We got it. We received the answers,
we paid them a million dollars. We received the
information, but we're doing nothing with it at
this point. It's not going to be published. We haven't paid the full amount of
the contract. What have we paid of the million dollars? I'm sorry?
What have we paid of the million whatever it was? Probably 900
and change. So we had $900,000 we paid for Disparity
study, and correct me if I'm wrong.
We define the scope because we issued the
RFP. So in an RFP, you define the scope of your project.
And if you define the scope of your project as to,
here are the particular questions. Here's the information
we want to look at. And they give us that. And it
has nothing to do with how we define the process,
then we shouldn't pay them a penny. If they did follow
it and gave us information that the data probably came
back and we didn't like it, then we should pay them and we
should release the data. And let us judge as to
was it effective or not, because I point back and
I say we had a process that we followed.
We didn't identify the scope. If they gave us the incorrect answers,
if we did identify the scope of the RFP and
they answered it based upon our scope check,
if they didn't, they shouldn't get a penny.
So while I can't delve into the substantive details
of this, this is really a legal matter at this point. I do want to
say that it's not a matter of not liking the final results.
And certainly we do define the scope. What we don't dictate is
methodology. That actually has to be something
that's independently decided by
the consultant. It's a little bit more nuanced and
then taken into account the existing programs that actually exist
for us. But I'm most
comfortable deferring questions about the disparity study to our legal department.
Fine. I understand.
Pay for play. There's another component that
we include into the bid process that awards points,
and I forgot what it's called to companies that are headquartered
here in the city. Hire Houston first. Hire Houston first.
So Ed Pollard answers the RFP and Dave Martin
answers the RFP. Ed Pollard.
Pollard. I'm assuming the objective of that is to get taxpaying
dollars. More of an opportunity to participate in our
business. Ed Pollard lives in the city. He works
for his company here that's based here. He has five employees.
Dave Martin lives in the City and Dave Martin has 600 employees
that live in the city of Houston. But yet he gets ten
points on a bid and I get zero. So if the objective
is to give opportunities to people, taxpayers, then why
do you look at that information and give him the points?
I've always had a big problem in our RFP process with this
because we have a number of companies that are great companies
in the city that employ a lot of people that
they lose bids on those ten points, but yet they have an
enormous employee force that lives in the city,
that are taxpayers and derive a lot of benefit.
But we give it to the small company who has a third
of those employees. I know it was passed by council
years ago, but why can't we look at that? Because that fundamentally
seems very unfair to me. So I do want to say that hire Houston first.
The designation which my office administers is not based on size.
Really? The criteria is that headquarters?
I'm sorry? Headquarters. That's what it's based on, correct? It's what isn't it
based on? Headquarters. Sorry to interrupt. It's actually based on principal place
of business. We have headquarters as an option, or 20%
of their workforce is actually locally based, but it's not a
size driven designation. So the City has
made a determination that for those companies that have actually
gone through the designation process and are declared as a local
business or a city business, that if they're competitive,
there's a leg up in the bidding process. So do
you think that was it? Higher Houston First
is a fair and equitable program
within the confines of what we do, it is.
But what we have found, I will say that our local companies
are actually very competitive. So our analysis on an
annual basis, we do publish a Higher Houston First report,
which we've been publishing for several years, actually shows that
our local companies are securing contracts without
the application of the Higher Houston First designation.
But it's there as a safety net in the event.
They're not competitive on their own. For the investments,
for the promoting the kind of investments that you described earlier, isn't it a 10%
variable? I'm sorry? Isn't it a 10% on an RFP process?
Isn't it a 10% equation?
Depending on the type of bid it is, I think it's like two to 3%
as long as you're within two to 3% of the lowest bid.
Good. So all my career, I've worked for a big firms
that weren't headquartered here. And we competed against really small
firms, and we had 600 people and they had five.
And I always felt that that was a very unfair deal
to give them the points, because sometimes we
may have lost business. I don't know. But I always thought if your
really objective is to give the opportunity to taxpayer citizens,
wow. Figure out how many you have that live here, pay taxes
here, and then compete against them and let the numbers
tell that story. But I'll get off my soapbox.
I'll be quiet over to Tiffany D.
Council Member Abby Cayman's office.
Good afternoon, Director. Mary. I have just one question on
behalf of Council Member Cayman. Due to the financial and budgetary constraints
the city continues to face from revenue limitations,
are there critical needs that your department are not able to address
at this time? And if there are, what are they? So,
as I mentioned earlier, we certainly struggling
in the contract compliance realm. And so the mayor is offering us funding,
us actually contracting out some of our
augmenting our existing contract compliance monitoring services
for a period of time. We have performed
analysis of how many people we do need to
perform contract compliance, effective compliance,
on a long term basis. And the numbers are
actually pretty high. And that's actually included in the appendix.
While we currently have seven compliance officers, we are anticipating
that we need about 30 to 37 compliance
officers. We have been working with HPW,
and Ms. Jackson actually
described some transfers that have been made,
personal transfers from the HPW department to facilitate
some of our compliance functions. But at this point,
we're not certainly the help that we'll receive via
vendors will be great, but long term,
we do need to augment our increase our
staffing.
Okay, Director Murray and Ms. Jackson, we have four public speakers who
are all in person here. And the first one we have is Mr.
Oliver, Jason Oliver.
He's the director of our Mic Communication Today and doing
a great job of it. I'll send you my invoice.
So management consulting has increased dramatically. I'm just trying to figure out
if that's where the contract compliance is showing up. Is that what's
happening there? The management consultant? Is that where we put this? It's about 520?
Yes. Okay. That's what I thought. Okay. Just making sure
you had talked about the 48,000 for
the contract compliance. How does that compare to peer peer
roles? And then the third
question that I want to ask is about the crisis Call
diversion funds that were approved and allocated last year. I know
that kind of falls under your purview. Those are
just now being put into use. Can you talk about the delay
in implementation there and kind of what factors into that?
Because it seems like the need for those diversionary calls
is significant, particularly during the pandemic.
Okay. Patsy, do you want to discuss the crisis call
diversion program was already being sponsored through
another source. We were just asked to
start to fund that source starting in 2021.
So it had already been funded before. It didn't just now start.
We just start to become a part of it.
So it's been affected before. Okay, so that
ARPA funding that's being used for that has been actualized
or it's not actually being used. I'm unclear on
what that means. So we're not going
to be poised to discuss any kind of ARPA funding as it
relates to that program as this fund focuses on the revenue that's
collected via the Pay option of Pay or play. Got you. Okay.
And as far as contract compliance, the competitiveness of
our salaries, we have done ad hoc
analyses looking at other
compliance officers in the state, particularly Austin.
And I know that our assistant director just came back from a
conference where she spoke with other practitioners
compliance contract compliance practitioners and certainly discovered
that our salaries are not, in fact, competitive.
Surprise, surprise. Thank you. Thank you,
Sarah. Blanding. Blanding.
I'm sorry. Hey, thank you so
much for all you do with so little.
And I'm just going to keep talking about these compliance
specialists because I've been obsessed with them since you all did your presentation last year.
I couldn't believe how many we needed versus what you all
actually had to operate with. And I appreciate
that there's been an effort for some sort of stop gap in the meantime,
and I appreciate to know that the
salaries are not competitive. Unfortunately, I'm not surprised.
I guess my question is, what do you need in order to expand to
the adequate number of compliance specialists to address our city's needs?
I'm just concerned there has not been a strong effort to address it. And I
guess that's honestly a side comment to the City Council, and I'd love to
see some budget amendments. So I'm
just curious what you all need, like what that dollar amount would be to
actually get that 30 to 37 in a competitive
salary.
Ideally, we would have all senior Business Development Coordinators, because I
would say that the level of work really rises to a senior compliance
level on a daily basis. And I'm
not really fantastic at multiplication, so I'd say
$58 to $60,000 times the
number of persons that are actually needed,
the 30 to 37. All right,
thank you. Adding to the two that we already
have, that's 2.1 million. Just if anyone wants to write that down,
got it. Thank you. Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair. The county recently did a Disparity
study, did they not? They did. It was published,
I think, maybe about a little bit over a year, a year and a half
ago. Do you know the firm that they used to do their Disparity study?
Do I know the firm? Are you familiar with the firm? I am.
Is it the same firm that we used? It is.
Okay. And so we use the same
firm as them. They publish theirs. We're not publishing ours. But we
spent almost a million dollars. My issue with
it is we keep talking about we have
budget restraints or we don't have the money to
pay for employees or whatever the case may be across the
board. But then we have a vendor who answered
the solicitation. We paid them almost a million dollars, but we're not
going to release the report when the county used
the same vendor for their report,
which actually highlighted a lot of the deficiencies that they had in their
program. I don't even think they had a program. Right. So I do think
while, again, I don't want to get into the
details of necessarily the issue
here, I do think it's important to note that the county did
not have a program. So you're starting with a clean slate.
And so the analysis of a nonexisting program and
contracting patterns versus a program that's actually been around
since 1984 and the nuances of such a
program is material to
how our Disparity studies actually conducted.
Thank you. So, Vice Chair legal's budget presentation
is Thursday at 01:00. And guess who will be sitting in the captain's
chair? You. So ask that question on
Thursday. Ms. Joe Groch.
Grochell did? Good the first time,
bad the second. My apologies. How are you?
Apology accepted. Thank you, ladies.
So I understand your mission is to convulse to cultivate a
competitive and diverse economic environment.
My question to you is, with $1.7
trillion in college debt and many people questioning
the value of a college degree, are efforts being made to
eliminate college from many job requirements by
promoting skills for, quote, unquote, new collar
jobs? So we're not specifically engaged
in efforts to eliminate college. Our workforce development team
is actually focused on just providing information
about different career pathways for Houstonians.
Okay, thank you. Okay. Thank you,
Mr. Butler.
Good afternoon, Director. I want to
talk about what could be compared to what you've guys been talking about,
of what is that will sort itself out. But I'm from
northeast Houston, and in my opinion, business creation
has been lacking for where I reside. So thus
it's the number one issue for me and the residents where I live.
So I'm curious if there is any possibility
going forward in an evolution not this
budget, next budget, but there are three things that I was wondering if you
could say, I see it in the stars or. No,
we're not structurally able to do it. The first one
is to launch a business incubator or accelerator in
conjunction with the HCC North Forest campus
that exists in my community. Also to create an
Office of Research and Evaluation charge with studying barriers
to wealth and business development in communities of color.
Lastly, establish an Office of Advocacy
and Intergovernmental Affairs to score the
effects of proposed legislation and regulations on barriers
to minority owned small business creation and success.
So for the last, establishing the Office
of Advocacy, that is definitely not something that I can commit
to. But I think for all three, what I can say to you is that
we welcome partnerships to explore these
areas that you've actually pointed out,
to see how we on our own with our existing resources.
I don't think this is something necessarily that we can do all three, but I
think in partnership with others, we can actually support some of the objectives of
those three items that you just listed. Right. It was a conversation about growing
into oneself compared to being that tomorrow.
Understood. Thank you. Okay, thank you.
And thank you, Director Murray. And Ms. Jackson. Appreciate your insight.
Thank you. Thank you.